I disagree a little bit I think Russia's
run by a bunch of thugs and Mobsters I
think Russia wants whatever is best for
Russia I don't think necessarily Russia
and China are these natural Partners I
think we made it that way I think what
Donald Trump was trying to do was he was
trying to keep Russia on some sort of a
kind of ambiguous middle neutral area
phase and then jab at China remember
Trump put he put sanctions on China he
you know improved a lot of diplomatic
diplomats be expelled from China he was
putting a lot of different he was trying
to kind of create some form of a jab
against the CCP the problem right now is
the CCP is able to run undeterred right
now there there is no counterbalance
from America so I mean look for example
if we had an actual regime that cared
about saving America like okay China
you're going down to Brazil to go do a
new deal 15 export now tariff
immediately on pick your product just
make him feel it a little bit a little
bit of you know make them think twice he
said there's no there's no cost to it